[Applaudissements]
le sport professionnel c'est totalement
arrêtées depuis le début de la crise les
gradins sont vides et il pourrait le
rester longtemps
oui lalonde et analystes et experts du
marché du sport bonsoir ray lalonde bon
sens le sport professionnel et c'est de
se donner un nouveau modèle d'affaires
il ya quelques activités quand même
qu'ils ont repris ça a été très possible
depuis à peu près trois semaines gerald
d'abord je pense à la bundesliga la
ligue de soccer professionnel en
allemagne une des grandes ligues
mondiales que commencer il ya déjà deux
week-ends sont allés de façon très
progressive très sécuritaire avec
d'énormes consignes pour les joueurs
pour les dirigeants pour les services
essentiels et ça a été bien réussi les
audiences télé en parallèle on est et on
atteint des chiffres record donc un
grand succès sami la table un peu pour
d'autres ligues d'autres organisations
sportives
on a vu le début de nascar sur la chaîne
fox aux états unis évidemment la course
automobile c'est un peu différent
on n'est pas trop attentif aux gradins
mais encore une fois un succès très
important et la ufc les arts martiaux
mixtes ont eu déjà trois ou quatre
soirées de combat
100 spectateurs mais avec une importante
contribution au niveau de télévision
payants alors jusqu'à maintenant tout va
bien est de plus en plus on voit le
défilement des lits qui se prépare à
lancer les ligues nord-américaines qui
commence donc dévoilé leur clan de
réouverture mais sans spectateurs ça
veut dire quoi est-ce qu'un modèle
d'affaires possible sans spectateurs
mais je pense que oui mais d'abord
gérald la première préoccupation au
niveau du basketball de la nba et joe
hockey de la ligue nationale
c'était de réduire les pertes anticipées
donc l'importance pour eux mêmes s'ils
terminent pas la saison régulière comme
c'était prévu d'au moins avoir des
séries éliminatoires de remettre un
trophée de championnat à la fin et de
récupérer le plus d'argent possible du
niveau des télédiffuseurs et d
commanditaire au niveau des séries ce
n'est pas ça c'est important parce que
pour une ligue où note ça peut
représenter plus de 500 millions de
dollars juste pour cette période
ça c'était vraiment important le modèle
économique du futur ou abricot de l'an
prochain 100 spectateurs
mais c'est mieux que de ne pas avoir de
produits en existence en actions dont
qui vont s'y faire ils vont s'adapter
ils vont peut-être réduire le nombre de
matches ils vont peut-être gardé des
équipes dans certaines villes seulement
ça va dépendre des marchés puis de la
pandémie
mais une chose qui est clair c'est que
les droits télé dans la plupart des lits
sont suffisants au hockey post-rock
heures mais dans les autres ligues c'est
suffisant pour garder les équipes
rentable pas au hockey
donc le hockey comme davantage sur la
billetterie wheeler qui compte pour à
peu près 60 à 70% des revenus d'une
équipe sur la vente de billets par le
membre de loges c'est à dire les revenus
gerald liées aux matches ça inclut aussi
la restauration les produits dérivés
vendus à l'intérieur de l'amphi terre
c'est très important mais c'est
simplement parce que les revenus
télédiffusion sont beaucoup moins élevés
que dans les trois grands sports
américains le football d'abord le
basketball et le baseball ensuite qui on
dénombre revenus on parle de milliards
de dollars annuellement qui reviennent
aux équipes et à la ligue ce qui fait en
sorte qu' ils ont les moyens de vivre
même simples spectateurs payants dans
les gradins alors c'est dangereux ce qui
se passe présentement pour la santé
financière de la ligue nationale de
hockey web et c'est dangereux pour
toutes les ligues mais ils ont tous
beaucoup d'argent en banque
des fonds d'urgence qui sont très
importants ils peuvent survivre
facilement à une année de toute façon
leur ok gérald a déjà eu 80 à 85% de
cette saison de jouer des jo il
s'apprête à faire un retour au jeu avec
les camps d'entraînement en juillet une
saison qui reste du début jusqu'à la fin
septembre début octobre
donc ils repos une énorme perte cette
année c'est l'an prochain qu'il faut
déjà envisager comment on va faire nos
frais avec 50 60 70 % moins de revenus
assurés et ensuite se bâtir une nouvelle
économie incluant les salaires des joies
et les plafonds salariaux
sont déjà engagées il ya beaucoup de
petits détails à régler d'ici stands et
qu'est ce que vous pensez donc de la
proposition du baseball majeur de
réduire le salaire des joueurs pour
limiter les dommages économiques sur le
secteur historiquement gerald ya eu
d'énormes conflit entre le baseball les
dirigeants et l'association des joies
cependant depuis une vingtaine d'années
les choses sont beaucoup plus calmes
beaucoup plus propice à des ententes qui
font en sorte qu'on peut s'enrichir des
deux côtés et ça a été un grand succès
le baseball actuellement vie très très
bien prétendez ni bon le problème c'est
que les propriétaires du baseball ont
décidé de faire une offre de jouer la
moitié de la saison
c'est à dire à peu près 80 de match mais
cependant ils ne veulent pas payer la
moitié des salaires il offre en retour
aux joueurs l'équivalent de 25% des
salaires
donc tu vas jouer 50 % la saison soit le
pays 25% de ton salaire alors la
réaction c'est les joueurs jusqu'à
maintenant a été de rejeter cette
proposition là il commence à manquer
tant du côté du baseball pour une saison
qui devrait en principe commencer à la
fête de l'indépendance américaine c'est
à dire le 4 juillet et on arrive en
début juin la semaine prochaine ils vont
manquer de temps s'ils n'arrivent sus
par s'entendre très bientôt et le risque
pour eux c'est qu'ils n'ont même pas
commencé la saison actuelle
contrairement aux basques baroque du
point de vue du consommateur en
terminant du partisan qu'est-ce qu'est
ce qui change
qu'est ce qui a changé mais on va avoir
une énorme consommation en termes de la
programmation sportive à partir du mois
de juillet ou septembre à tous les
sports vont presque à bord lui en même
temps et ça va être intéressant de voir
qu'ils vont réussir à attirer
l'attention des consommateurs à la télé
ou sur les écrans web
ça c'est le premier point notre vie va
changer de toute façon généralement on
consomme toujours le sport de façon que
les visuels
parce que c'est rare les occasions qu'on
est là en direct dans un archipel du
sportif ça c'est une chose mais l'an
prochain
si on pense qu'en 2021 la prochaine
saison de sport il est assuré d'avoir
des gens dans les gradins
j'en doute fortement la contamination
c'est un vrai problème dans les
rassemblements sportifs parce qu on est
si près leur look en plus on est très
pendant de longues heures ce qui
encourage la contamination
donc la tulle
gerald c'est loin d'être sûr qu'on va
voir le nouveau normale dès l'an
prochain
à mon avis on a besoin d'à peu près 2 3
ans pour absorber économiquement les
effets de la pandémie sur le sport et
aussi pour se réaligner au niveau du
calendrier très intéressant c'est long
ça va être long effectivement des gens
devront être très patient bien sûr dans
les circonstances où est la longue merci
merci beaucoup